how much you weigh how much right now or
no when you fight you fight 175 yeah but
i want to i
i want to be a champion in the third no
that's cool universal that's a different
fight i know cooper why don't you fight
um
[ __ ] well why don't you [ __ ] hey why
can't he fight i'm homeboy
who 168 pound champion
canelo yeah we'd love the canelo fight
that would
i'd love the canelo i gotta cut off my
leg one of the legs to make 160. no no
wait a second for that kind of money
we'll cut off his leg
right now he listened 1994
that one he fought out 75. so you're
going to be a 75
fight no it wouldn't be for you to go
down to 16.
unless before now i have a month
vacation
after that if if
we get a huge opportunity for something
like that with canelo yeah i'll find
another fighter once again but if not
why don't you ask for it yeah but he won
a unified be undisputed at 168.
and he was supposed to fight kayla plant
in september he killed
i thought he fought him right here and i
i believe caleb's going to box
you know kayla playing i can't listen
caleb ain't laughing yeah
he don't plan to outbox canelo alvarez
mike
no maybe the first couple rounds maybe
for 12 rounds canelo
canelo is going to get out boxed by
caleb plant i said it on hotbox
mike he's smooth but he doesn't he
doesn't have a power
the only thing he don't have experience
he's gonna give clockworld
i think
he's white he can box he looks like from
floyd mayweather
look at it look at this slick slick
slick
wait did that [ __ ] start
hitting that body
yeah alvarez hit that
can i tell you guys the biggest threat i
think let's look at him fighting i want
to
see
this uh put the put the uh david look at
this [ __ ]
yeah 168 yeah mike look how slick mike
look how slick he is
oh he's going to get [ __ ] up he's the
one
with those opponents that's the thing
but he got the skills but he just got it
got
more experience i think can can can i
say something about that i feel like he
still has a lot of a lot of
amateur like there's people that have
that thump you know what i'm saying
canelo has that [ __ ] thump
i know this you know what caleb's got
what a lot of guys don't caleb buried
his daughter when she was two years old
yeah
he's got that killer attitude where
respect that anything's possible but i'm
telling you man
okay can we look up on david benavidez
can we look him up
why don't he fight better feeders
they don't like each other that would be
a
mexican he's got finesse mic
now he's just like killing the beast
yeah he's a killer he ain't got no
finesse though caleb got the finesse he
got the just the power
and he constantly
[Laughter]
he's got everything dude that benefit
well he he's
wrong yeah but again caleb outboxes both
of these guys
oh we got cko kayla this is some
[ __ ]
kayla your white ass
again that's part of the marketability
oh yeah the complexion is white it's not
you're not used to seeing somebody like
that yeah do that well
he got the complexion for the protection
but he's gonna be in some [ __ ] with this
mexican
no jackpot henry caleb's gonna outbox
all right listen canelo let's put in
canelo's last fight
wait wait but you're you're ever you're
you're measuring them with with billy
joel saunders yeah but he's also a good
fighter though
billy joel he's the olympian he's a two
two division world champion
he's going to beat whoever standards
could be caleb no no okay
nope so so the thing that canelo is
going to possess is power billy joe
doesn't have power he's
slick he can move he's actually like a
54-pounder the national
smaller guy yeah so you know canelo i
know about caleb
would actually he'd be considered short
for you guys as weight class two right
super he's like five
nine five won a world title at 168. he
was i had his title
yeah i know but you know this is that
money right here yeah this is the money
he's got retirement but i'm not going to
wait two three years just to not move up
because who's that cruiserweight there's
nobody really but i i i
don't like the cup wait what was the
europeans up there yeah all the russians
europe as an african guy
that got the macabre he got the wbc
i don't even know who got the other
there's never been money in
cruiserweight you know
not until badou like to cut weight
i don't like the cup weight and i know i
love losing weight
yeah he's heavyweight